ERIC KLOPFER: Educational technologies
have the potential to transform how we
teach and learn, but realising that
potential is a significant challenge.
To be effective, these
technologies need to be
designed based on what we
know about how people learn
and how they interact with technology.
Learning, however, is not
a straightforward matter.
Knowledge can be as
complex as the students
and groups of students
engaged in learning.
That's why it's helpful
to have an understanding
of existing educational
theories, frameworks,
and rich history of
previous efforts that
can inform the design
of learning experiences.
Hello, I'm Eric Klopfer.
I'm a professor of education at MIT,
where I run the Scheller Teacher
Education program and
the Education Arcade.
You're here because you have
an interest in the enterprise
of educational technology, be it the
development aspects, product design,
or the underlying theories.
So welcome to Design and Development
of Educational Technology,
the first of MIT's Ed
TechX course series.
We hope and expect that you come
from a variety of backgrounds
with varied experience in
education and/or technology.
This course is different--
or at least I hope it is.
We're not only trying to teach
you about some important past
and present educational technologies,
and good pedagogical practices,
but we're also trying to practice what
we preach through the course itself.
Throughout this course, we'll
travel across the nation
to talk with a variety of experts
working with educational technology,
including educators,
researchers, and developers.
Through interviews, informal lectures,
and on-location case studies,
we'll hear more about
the tools they designed,
the theories their
designs were based on,
and what they found out
about how they were used.
This course culminates
in a final project--
a Kickstarter-style pitch for
a new educational technology
that will serve as
proof of your learning.
There will be no grades.
This is your chance to design your own
technology-based learning experience
and gather feedback from your peers.
The real source of learning in this
course, however, comes from you.
Throughout this six-week course,
you'll be an active participant
engaging with the exciting
ideas introduced in the course
through your projects and your
interactions with fellow learners.
In fact, developing this course
is part of our own process
here at MIT-- of discovering what works
best in online learning environments.
This is only the beginning.
Educational technology is
a rapidly-expanding field,
but the best practitioners
know that you can't just
mash education and technology
together carelessly.
It's a delicate process
to develop technology
from an educational approach, and
here, at Design and Development
of Educational Technology,
we'll show you how.
We're excited to begin
the adventure with you.